in Marvel Comics there's a character
named Spider-Boy his name is actually
Bailey Briggs but he's the Spider-Man
that nobody remembers he's had a whole
bunch of adventures with Peter Parker
and Miles Morales and ultimately
sacrifice himself so why doesn't anybody
remember this character because Bailey
was stabbed by a totem dagger what does
that mean in Marvel Comics every single
spider character Spider-Man spider Gwen
Spider Woman Miles Morales they're all
connected through something called the
web of life and Destiny when a person is
stabbed with a totem dagger they're
severed from the web of life and Destiny
in effect it wipes them from existence
not only are they white from existence
all knowledge of them having ever
existed is wiped from existence which is
why Peter and Miles don't remember who
he is but now he's back so the question
has to be asked what's gonna happen next
make sure you guys follow for more